-Welcome back, everybody.
We're hanging out with
Maisie Williams,
and we're about to
play a new game
called Like, Follow, Block.
♪ -Like, follow, block, yeah ♪
♪ Like, follow, block, yeah ♪
-So, to start you off, I'm going
to give you three choices,
and you'll have to tell me,
out of the three,
which one would you
like a post from,
which one you'd follow,
and which one you would block.
Sound good?
-Absolutely.
-Alright, let's start
with our first three options.
Tacos, pizza, and burgers.
Maisie?
-Okay.
I would like pizza.
This is a hard one.
-Yeah, it is.
-I'd like the posts of pizzas.
-Mm-hmm.
-And then I would follow tacos,
because I could eat those
all day every day, and I want to
see those posts coming in.
And then I'd
have to block burgers.
-What?! Wow!
-I know.
-But hey.
It's not me playing.
Here we go. Who cares?
Next round, here we go.
We have spinning, we have yoga,
and we have treadmill.
-Okay. Spinning needs to die.
I hate it.
-I agree, I agree.
-Block, the worst.
-Never, yes, I don't even
like it on the screen.
I'm going to look elsewhere.
-Get away.
I can't even look at it.
The treadmill also sucks,
but we have to put it somewhere,
so let's say that we'll like.
And then yoga,
I actually enjoy yoga.
You can go very, very slow
and basically just stretch
and you don't have to
work that hard,
so we'll follow yoga.
-Ah, I love this.
This is so good.
Alright, let's do
another round here.
You have ketchup stain
on the shirt,
something stuck in your teeth,
and accidently swallowing a bug.
Well, come on.
-Oh, man.
-Let's say no one saw you
swallow the bug.
-Okay.
Well, I don't know.
Food in the teeth is pretty
horrible when that happens.
And when it happens to someone
else, I can't just ignore it.
I will just be like,
"There is food in your mouth."
-You will?
That's a good friend.
-Yeah, I'm staring at it,
and they're talking to me
and I just think,
"I have to tell you
there's a massive piece of food
in your teeth."
And they usually get quite sad
about it, but it is what it is.
But I block that,
because it sucks. It's horrible.
-Yep.
-Ketchup stain, I'll follow.
You know, why not?
It's okay.
It happens a lot.
It's an easy thing to happen.
And then swallow a bug,
I guess like swallowing a bug.
I mean, I'm not --
It always, you know --
It feels kind of like lucky,
you know?
It's quite rare that it happens
and you're like, "Oh."
-Lucky, oh, my God.
Lucky bug.
Okay, here we go, last round.
We have BTS, One Direction,
and the Backstreet Boys.
-Okay, wow.
-This is good.
-Stan BTS, all day, every day.
Follow and like.
One Direction, also, you know,
whichever, follow, like.
And then Backstreet Boys, like,
come on, guys. Bye.
-No! Really?!
Oh, Maisie, Backstreet Boys,
though, they're great.
-They haven't been relevant
since I was born. I'm sorry.
-Oh, my gosh.
They haven't not been relevant.
[ Both laugh ]
This has all been fun.
I'm getting to know you
more and more and more.
That was awesome.
Maisie Williams, everybody.